In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sina Xadion from May 19th, on which we commemorate St. Dmitri Donskoi,
Grand Prince of Moscow.
The son of John, Grand Prince of Vladimir and Moscow, St. Dmitri was born in 1350.
Brought up in a great spirit of piety, the young prince passed most of his time in prayer,
and envisiting the holy places.
Under the spiritual direction of the holy metropolitan Alexis, who, on his father's death in 1359,
took on the Regency, he learned to carry out the duties of his state in conformity with
evangelical principles to seek in all things the glory of God.
The long and implacable tonner domination had reduced Russia to a parless state, and everything
needed rebuilding, especially on the moral and spiritual level.
Divine providence confided to Prince Dmitri, this task of the renovation of the kingdom and
the church, to prepare for the definitive throwing off of the Mongol yoke, while, on the spiritual
plane, St. Surgis of Redness and his disciples presented the monastic life to the people as
a model of Christian perfection.
He was under the direction of the St. Alexis, Surgis, and Theodore, Archbishop of Rostov,
and thanks to the beneficent influence of his devout wife, St. Odossia, that the Grand
Prince first undertook the unification of the various Russian principalities and the assurance
of the church's independence.
After a victory over the Prince of Susdal, ironed his allies, he had, in addition to having
to face external enemies, the totters and the Lithuanians, the jealous rivalries of the
princes of Riazhan and Tefer.
He received their submission in 1375 but did not take advantage of this victory to plunder
or occupy their cities.
The goal of his policy was to create a unified state through the principalities' free submission
to the Grand Prince of Moscow, following the model of the mutual love of the persons
of the Holy Trinity.
Often visiting St. Surgis' monastery, he became his fellow worker in the task of spiritual
Renaissance and founded many monasteries, placing the St. disciples at their head.
During this time, the totter-yoke being lifted in Russia because of internal difficulties in
the Golden Horde, the situation had raised various hopes in the subject people.
But they lacked the spirit of cohesion and organization, and it was this task that Grand Prince
Dimitri sholdered from 1370 onwards.
In 1378, a great totter army, having as their goal to penetrate as far as Moscow, invaded
the principality of Riazhan.
St. Dimitri and his army went to meet them and carried off an initial victory.
In 1380, Khan Mumai, raising a vast army in all his vassal kingdoms, entered Russia with
almost 400,000 men, realizing that the decisive movement which providence had been preparing
since his childhood had arrived, the Grand Prince harvesting the fruits of his patient policy
of the reuniting of the Russian principalities, assembled a powerful army near Moscow, under
the slogan, God is our refuge and our strength.
After the feast of the Dormition, he went to the monastery of the Holy Trinity, and Saint
Surges gave him his blessing to engage in battle against the godless, for telling victory
for him.
On the eve of the Nativity of the Mother of God, the troops, at the head of which the Prince,
like a second Constantine, had placed the life-giving cross, crossed the dawn and arrived on the plane
of Kulikoval.
The time for battle, having come, Saint Dimitri addressed his men, saying,
My dear brothers, let us fight for God, for the holy churches, and for the Christian faith.
If we must die, this death is not death but eternal life.
Do not think of any earthly thing, my brothers.
Let us not abandon the battle, and we shall then be victoriously crowned by Christ our God
and the Savior of our souls.
It was a novice from Saint Surges monastery who first launched himself into the battle, and
was the first victim.
It was a terrible battle.
The greatest that the land of Russia had ever known.
Men not only died in the scrum, but were also trotten underfoot by the crowd of soldiers
who pressed forward in the two narrow plane.
During this time, Saint Surges was able to see in spirit the progress of the battle, and
gave the names of the victims for Pani Kivas to be celebrated in their memory.
The Russian army finally carried off a brilliant victory which constituted a decisive stage in
liberation from the Tatar Yoke, and the creation of the Russian state.
The Battle of Kulikovo became the symbol of the spiritual and national awakening of the
Russian people, and the victory of the light of Christ over the darkness of paganism.
On his return to Moscow, the Grand Prince, after having been healed of his wounds, knew
no peace.
In 1382, a Tatar army under Khan, Tautamik, devastated Moscow and forced him to flee to
Kostroma.
But in spite of the damage inflicted on the city, the Taters were incapable of securing their
position, and the movement for emancipation continued to run its course.
But Prince Dimitri, however, being able to enjoy the results.
Exhausted by illness, he handed his power over to his eldest son, Basil, and after having
received the sacraments at the hands of Saint Surges, gave his soul into God's hands on
the 19th of May in 1389, at the age of 40.
Under the prayers of our Holy Father's, O Lord, Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us
and save us.